- Let's say the playoffs come right now.
- If the playoffs were right now?
- Starting right now, yeah.
- You know, obviously the Lakers are doin' their thing.
They got a superteam over there, but that doesn't excite me.
- If the Knicks were the same—
- If the Knicks had that team, that still doesn't mean that
they're gonna go out and win.
It's the Knicks.
[Laughing]
- What's up?
This is Serge Ibaka,
aka Mafuzzy Chef. Welcome to "How Hungry Are You?"
Today, I'll be cooking for Action Bronson.
- I'm not expecting anything but happiness and joy.
That's what I hope for every day of my life.
- Action is a seafood lover, and today I'll be cooking him bullfrog.
Ohhh! It touched my face!
[Laughing]
First step, I have to boil the frog.
This is not seafood,
but this live in water too.
Now, I'm going to make a fondue
cheese sauce.
Let's go.
- [Offscreen]: What do you think Serge will
cook for you today?
- I don't know.
I've seen some of these things, so I'm a little bit worried to be
honest with you.
But I'm also interested.
- We got the oil here.
You see how I'm pouring it smoothly?
That's how you do it.
Now, I'm gonna take out the frog.
I have only two secrets. I'm sure you know.
Salt and pepper.
We're gonna add hot cheese to the pot.
Oh, this is gonna taste so good.
[Laughing]
- How are you, sir?
- Oh, hey. What's up, what's up?
- How you feelin'?
- Welcome, brother.
- Great to see you.
- Yes, sir. Good to see you too. You can sit here, man.
- Yeah, that's a good height for you. I'm just good standing.
- Oh, wow. Actually, yeah.
- Yeah, nah. I feel perfect like this.
This is my, this is my height right here.
- Well, you know what? You can stand because nobody gonna know.
- Exactly.
- Only me. Only me.
- Only you.
- Exactly.
How are you?
- I'm good.
- You good?
- Yeah, I just got up.
- Got up?
- Like, woke up.
- From, from nap?
- Yeah, I was napping.
I put myself into a little nap.
Yeah? You know, I'm glad you say that.
I wanted to ask you—
- Tell me.
- Are you high?
- Come onnn.
- [Laughing]
- Of course not.
- No?
- Of co—
- OK, no, it's just a simple question.
I'm glad you—
- The thing is, it's not a high.
I'm just—I'm where I need to be.
- OK. Not too high, not too low.
- It's just here. It's all about here.
Because if you get too much here—
- Too high?
- Or too there, you know,
then you're never gonna be there.
- Yeah. It stays—consistency.
- Exactly. You know?
- All right. I see you.
I see you.
How long you been rapping—you been in the game?
[DJ scratching]
- Word.
I been rappin', like, uh, I don't know.
Ten years now.
- Ten years now?
- Yeah. March is gonna be the 10-year
anniversary of my first project, called
"Dr. Lecter." It's
actually pretty f--king crazy.
Pardon my language.
- Yeah, you know—
- You curse here, or what do you do?
- No, no. This is, uh, PG-13.
- Come on.
That's still curse.
They let "f--k" through once in a while
in PG-13 movies.
OK, so, so—OK, go—let's go PG-10. How 'bout that?
- All right, so, just PG.
- So just make sure it's clean. PG.
- Like "Home Alone."
- OK.
So you're from New York.
- I'm from right here.
- Are you a Knicks fan?
- Of course, man. I'm, you know, yes.
[Laughing]
- Like, you the kinda fan—like,
you gonna die for your Knicks.
- Come on, man. I've been a Knicks fan since—
- Good and bad.
- Yeah. You stay with your team—
- You stay true.
- You stay with your allegiance.
- I like that.
- Yeah, always.
- I like that. I like that.
- Always.
- What do you think about this season so far?
- Psh.
- And the rookie—
- Garbage. It is what it is.
- And the young fella, rookie—what
do you think about him?
- He looks good. He looks like
he can score. He can score.
We need some work.
- The way you say it, like—
- He's young. I'm—see, when we start talkin'
about the Knicks, everything goes out the window.
- You don't think you got future?
I think he, he—
- I think he has a future, but what I'm sayin'
is, I'm a harsh critic, you know?
I wanna see more.
- You need to see more. But he's a rookie, so takes time.
- I know. I'm givin' him time.
- Give him time, OK.
- Knox was a rookie. I need to see more.
Three years later, I need to see more.
- All right.
- I like Ja Morant.
I think he's a game-changer.
Like, an Iverson.
He's just tough.
I wanted the Knicks to get him.
That's the guy.
- Besides the Knicks, right now—
- Yeah.
- All right? Let's say the playoffs come right now.
- If the playoffs were right now?
- Starting right now, yeah.
- You know, obviously the Lakers are doin' their thing.
They got a superteam over there, but that doesn't excite me.
- No? Why?
- Because it doesn't.
- Why not?
- It's not fair. It's not fair.
- You say—oh, you say—
- It's not fair.
- Oh, you're saying that because it's
not your team. If the Knicks was the same—
- If the Knicks had that team?
- Yeah, would you be—
- I would acknowledge that it wasn't fair.
But that still doesn't mean that they're
gonna go out and win. It's the Knicks.
- [Laughing]
- But come on, now.
It's all about havin' those right amount of guys.
Those guys that jell.
Like, you know, with the Toronto team,
guys that just jelled. You know?
- A couple of stars on the team.
But other than that, good jell.
It's like, L.A. Look.
- [Laughing]
- The Raptors. Did you see, did you see—
- Did I see your glory? Yeah.
- Did you see us?
- Of course. Yeah, I watched the whole playoffs.
It was unbelievable.
- Oh, yeah?
- The whole run.
- What did you think about us?
- I mean, I don't know.
Kawhi is that guy.
- Kawhi's the guy.
- Kawhi is that guy.
- Yeah.
- You played unbelievable.
- Thank you.
- You know, there was a lot of Siakam.
Van Cleef—was that his name? Van Cleef?
- No, Van Cleef, no.
- Oh, that's the, that's the watch.
What's his name?
- Freddy VanVleet.
- Who?
- VanVleet. Freddy.
- Van de what?
- Freddy VanVleet.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Laughing]
- Can you say it?
- En francais?
- No.
- No what?
- In English. Say his name in English.
- What's his name, uh—
- Freddy VanVleet.
- Frankie Vondalay?
- Huh?
- Nah.
- Freddy Vondalay.
- Noah Vondalay? What's his name?
- Yeah, like you say, Vondalay.
- He did his thing.
- Yeah.
- He, he played—that's what it takes.
It takes people to come outta the
woodworks and just give an unbelievable
performance that was unexpected.
- Yes, sir.
- And that's what it takes.
- It took that shot in Philly.
- The Kawhi shot?
- Oooh.
- That was a crazy shot.
- And it was like, it was like
you just leaning until it goes in.
Heavy duty. Lots of drama.
It was fun.
- It was fun, huh? So, New York
Knicks fan, right?
- Yes.
- But you have to give credit
to the Nets. The move they did
this summer, right?
- Come on, man.
- Listen, you have to give them credit.
- I can't give any credit to some—I can't—
- No, no. Listen, I know—
- My team—
- You die for Knicks—
- Listen, the Knicks—Yeah, OK, it was a great move.
- But give credit—
- But big deal.
- Where the credit is.
- OK, but—OK. Great.
Yeah, obviously
we wanted KD here.
Thats what we want.
We wanted that duo here, right?
- Yeah.
- But we didn't get it. So I'm sour.
- Kyrie is still—he's taking
off when he wants.
He's—
- Who, who told you that?
- I'm watching it!
- No, you watching or you heard
it from the social media and the news?
- I don't look at that
type of stuff.
- The fake news!
- I look at memes.
- [Laughing]
- Because he—
- I don't look at, like, sports
social media. I watch with my own
eyes.
- Yeah?
- I just know what I see.
- Kyrie needs to start playin' more,
you know? He's tryin' to be—
- He's hurt!
- You know, he's gonna be the floor general.
- He was hurt.
- What did he do? What was wrong with him?
- He was hurt. They say he was hurt.
- What happened?
What happened?
[Laughing]
- He was hurt. Right?
- Who knows? That's what they say.
- That's what they say. Exactly, so—
- I, I've definitely faked knee
injuries as well.
If I did a move and I missed the shot,
"Ohhh, my hamstring."
Listen, at the end of the day,
you just wanna see good basketball.
You wanna see people that
are on the team play every day,
because that's what it's about,
right?
- Yeah. But do you—I'm gonna
tell you something.
Do you know it's a lot when you,
when you watch basketball, you
watch us play. Now I'm, I'm
talking to you as, as an athlete.
- Of course.
- When you watch us play,
do you know, we play with a
lot of things going on, and
how bad it is. Sometimes you guys
don't know.
- Of course.
- Right?
- Well, you think I'm doin' this—
I'm fully healthy right now?
[Laughing]
- I'm on the injury report right now
too, my brother. You know?
Like, I come here with a hurt foot.
But I still played through it.
- You still coming, that's right.
- Yeah, but I'm not tryna—
- Thank you.
- That's the thing—
- Yes, sir.
- And I'm not gonna tell anybody, you know?
That was supposed to be hidden.
I wasn't even limpin'.
I came in ready. Just in case we
were gonna run a one-on-one or somethin'.
- [Laughing]
- You rap about, like, balling, like
basket—you know, basketball, football.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Can you ball?
- Of course. My—you don't
even understand. My jump shot has
been wet since age seven.
Just...whew. Wet.
- Just like that.
- I'm serious. Listen, the first
time I stepped foot into Madison
Square Garden?
- Yeah.
- I went 8-for-12, three-point line.
- Against who?
- Just by myself.
- By yourself.
- [Laughing]
- Just—but come on, as soon
as I stepped on the court, oooh.
- Swish.
- There's no games.
- So what NBA player would you
compare to your game?
- Allen Iverson.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- OK. Allen Iverson.
- Because, you know, he doesn't
really need to practice. He was
kinda born with—
- Gift.
- He was born this way.
- Yeah.
- You know? So, I'm gifted
in all these facets as well.
- You're a rapper, a chef, an
author, a TV star.
- Yeah.
- How did you get casted in "The Irishman" movie?
- Yeah, "The Irishman." Of course—
- I mean, "Irishman," right?
- Yeah, that's the one.
- How'd you get cast in the movie? "Irishman?"
- I don't know. I guess they liked
my look.
- ...so—
- My look, this.
- This look.
- With this look, it fit the
theme of the movie, and it fit
that part.
- So, when we watch movies, do they
cast people by the look too?
- Of course. They cast people by
the look. You know, you goin' for a—
- I went in and read.
- Yeah?
- It was—I bombed. It was terrible.
But they still gave me a part.
Maybe I wasn't as bad as I thought.
- Do you, do you have fun doing that?
Do you enjoy it?
- Yeah, it was incredible.
- It was fun, huh?
- It was, like, me and De Niro right
here talkin' to each other.
- I know, big time.
- Like, I had to walk—you know how hard
it is for someone to be telling you
that you have to do a walk-and-talk?
So it was like this.
Literally I had lines—
- Yeah, show me.
- I had to start here. And then
I'm givin' him all kinds of things.
I'm talkin' like this: blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
And I gotta hit certain points. I
gotta make sure I look at the camera,
expose my left side, you know
what I mean?
- It's hard?
- It's not an easy thing.
- It's, it's hard?
- Yes. We knocked it out in, like,
four takes. You know, we don't like
to do too many cuz, you know, once
you get it, you get it.
- Yeah.
- If you don't get it, you don't got it.
- You don't get it, right.
So now it's time for our
Spicy Questions.
I'm gonna ask you questions.
- Yeah.
- And you, you have to answer.
- OK.
- If you don't answer, I have
a surprise for you.
- OK.
- OK?
- This is your beer. It's your own drink.
- OK. But you mixed it with somethin'.
- It's mixed with crickets.
- Oh, nice. I like those.
- OK? And it's spicy.
This is your crickets.
- Where are the crickets from?
- Huh?
- Where are they from?
- From Congo.
- Oh, from Congo. OK.
- Yeah. It's original cricket tea.
- I have never had a Congo cricket.
- OK then.
A little extra crickets.
Are you ready?
- It better not be math problems.
- [Laughing]
- Pullin' out all kinds of—I'm
good at "Jeopardy!"
- OK, who was the worst artist
you have done a song with?
- [Laughing]
- The worst one.
- You was like, "Man!"
- I'mma just start saying random names.
- No, don't say random names.
- This guy, Leonardo, he was terrible, man.
- Who? What's his name?
- Leonardo.
- Leonardo?
- Yeah.
- That's his rapper name?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's his name?
- No, he wasn't a rapper.
He was a singer. It was—
- A singer? From where?
- From, uh, France.
- From France?
- Yeah, man. It was terrible.
- You—are you making those names?
- No, what are you talkin' about?
- [Laughing]
- Come on, man.
- I'm serious.
- Are you making?
- Wait, are you—
Wait, do you get to also combat
whether I'm saying the right thing?
I'm answerin' the question!
Leonardo!
- Leonardo. Can—OK, can—
- [Offscreen:] What song?
- No, no, no, no.
- What song? What song?
Leonardo, what song?
- It's called "Don't Lean on My Shoulder."
- No.
- I'm serious!
- I don't buy that.
Can you Google me that song please right now?
- No, no, no. You can't use Google!
- No, because—
- What is this?
- Exactly.
[Laughing].
- Psh, might as well try this.
- [Laughing]
- Go ahead. That one.
- That was good. I like it.
What's the next question?
- You like that?
- I do.
- OK, good.
- Oh, there's a leg.
- Yeah, there's a leg?
- Yeah.
- [Laughing]
- There's a wing.
- It's a wing and leg.
[Laughing]
- There's another wing.
- Last one. You ready?
- Yeah.
- Can you rap a freestyle about
the NBA right now? Like, just right now.
- No. If you're a pure artist, you do
it when you want and when you feel,
not when someone asks.
- I mean, I'm asking nicely. Please.
- Yeah, but that—
- I said—OK, please?
- Yes, but that's makin' me wanna
do it less. Trust me, I don't know.
Absolutely not, so whatever.
- OK then—wait, wait, wait, wait.
- Put more, put more.
Let 'em soak for a second.
- [Laughing]
- The juice is actually good. That's
all it's about. That's all Tabasco?
- It's your, it's your beer.
Before you put—before you take this drink—
- Nah, that's beer and Tabasco?
- Yeah, it's your beer!
- I couldn't even tell.
- You couldn't tell because we
mixed it good.
- That's good.
- Yeah.
- You wanna try it? Try it, man,
come on.
- Lemme try your beer.
- Take the one that doesn't have
too much cricket in it.
- Yeah, I'mma try your beer now.
- I like that.
If you fry those up with some
ginger, scallion and garlic—
- [Clearing throat] All right.
- Come on. That's good.
- My man.
- Come here. Bring it in.
- Yes, sir. All right!
How hungry are you?
- I'm not that hungry. I had
a little something before I came.
- All right.
- Yeah.
- Just a little something.
I heard you like seafood, right?
- I gotta be honest with you.
I hate seafood.
- [Laughing]
- I do not eat seafood.
- So—
- You asked me if I like it? No.
- OK.
- Will I try it? Yes.
- Yes, all right.
Tonight, I cooked frog
fondue for you.
- Ooooh. See, I think that this
is prepared in the proper way.
- Ah, yeah.
- But—
- It's cold.
- The way you word it, it make, like,
it's, it's not hot.
- Just lemme just be honest with you.
- It's not hot.
- I would love to try that, but that
seems to be in the temperature danger zone.
- Temperature—
- [Laughing]
- I'm serious. I'm certified
by the board.
- Try it. Give it a try.
- That looks like a good lil'
nugget right there.
- Oh, oh you goin'.
- Come on, you know I'm goin'
for the hamstring.
- Wait, wait. We got a fondue
right now.
- Lookin' at how you're holding my arm.
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
- Why are you holding my arm like this?
- Wait, wait, wait.
I got, I got something. Wait, I got
something. Don't move.
Stay like that. Don't move. I got something
for you. Don't move.
- Oh, nah. Here, we gonna do this.
- All right.
- Can I make a little crostini?
- Now you can do it.
You tell me what it feel like.
Be careful, it's hot.
- That tastes pretty good.
- Yeah. Told you.
- What is it?
- Huh?
- What's in there?
- It's frog leg. It's cheese.
- Cheese and what? What type of cheese?
Gruyere?
- It's a, a Gruyere cheese.
- It's good. You wanna try some?
- It's good, right?
- Can I make you some crostini?
- I'll try. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, no,
I'm tryin'. I'm tryin' it out.
- Let me give you the hamstring.
It's the best part, look.
- Yeah, I'm gettin' that one.
- Here, come on. I gotchu.
Have that. Trust me.
It's fire. That's tremendous.
That's a good job, man.
I'm very happy with that.
- You good.
- Take some of that bread, and
try some of this olive oil for me, please.
Dunk the bread in that olive
oil, please. Immediately.
- This your brand?
- I curated this with
a friend of mine named
Nicholas Coleman.
- OK.
- He is the top oleolgist in this world.
- It's good.
- This oil right here is one of Sicily's
most rare olives. You eat that,
it's gonna be good for your brain.
- Yeah?
- You're gonnna be able to make
faster decisions on the court.
- OK.
- [Laughing]
- So, Jordi—
- It's also good for your skin.
- Your skin.
- Everything. You put it on the
baby's head—
- Must be smooth.
- Dunk the baby in the olive oil.
Just hold it by the foot and
just dunk 'em.
- Ah, man.
- I'm serious.
This was great, guys.
- Yeah.
- I really appreciate you brotha.
- My man.
- Come on, man. For the 55th time.
- Yessir, yessir, yessir, yessir.
- You the man.
- My man. Thanks for coming, man.
Thanks, was a pleasure.
- Fun. Good times.
I love you. Thank you.
[Applause]
- Hold on just a second. Battery
just went down.
- Oh, my God. Get the stunt camera
in here.
- [Offscreen:] I gotchu. I gotchu.
- But we—we're just holding
this now. Look at this.
My forearm is hurting.
- There we go. All right.
Hey, count of three.
One, two, three.
All right, thank you.
- That was good, man.
- My man. I appreciate it, bro.
- Much love.
- Yes, sir.
- Thank you, guys. Be safe.
- Thank you for coming again.